the mmqb is terrific must read material
for him and he was the one who was
reporting last night about
what uh was on antonio brown's
vaccination card and so much and so
forth and here also to face some music
is one of my friends from the basketball
school in columbus ohio wow albert
brewer how are you doing albert
i guess you could say this is a
conversation 10 years in the making
right well you could say that yeah you
could say that
hey you know and i i really enjoyed
listening to ryan shay's here on your
show earlier this week i didn't catch
that and um you know i i'll i'll give
you a little insight to the way we think
uh when you say what do you mean we what
do you mean we like all of us all of us
who's all of us who went to school there
i i mean you know maybe at some schools
um your basketball team knocking off the
number one team in the country would
stop in the blow of a football loss
not in columbus no not at ohio state
that's too bad and ryan gazier said it
correctly
we are not a basketball school we're a
football school and we do not run to
basketball when things aren't going
right in football we are a football
school so i appreciate ryan saying that
earlier in the week and i am happy to
take any medicine you can dish out
because
they
i mean michigan played great they played
great and they deserve to win the game
no question about it thank you albert
that's very nice of you and i i just
think i think that's that that's that's
very high road of you and i hope that
you're not passing out right now from
the lack of oxygen if you have how much
of a high road that you've taken albert
i mean i could i could go down the list
of tweets that you sent in my direction
in the last uh a few years where the
road was very low i mean they're very
very low
you know i appreciate you i appreciate
you waiting until friday because if this
conversation that happened on monday it
might have gone a little different well
it was before the big win for your
basketball team to help you know
uh like like i said that didn't that
didn't do much um i think
i i think that um yeah i think i can
speak for everybody who's you know in
columbus that uh this one's gonna this
one this one leaves a mark no question
well then let's get to that just uh in
all seriousness like what what what is
the adjustment here because as you know
uh harbaugh made some adjustments uh
this past year
and um a lot of that has to do with the
fact that don brown couldn't defend the
the defense that was terrific against
everybody was just uh ripe for ryan's
day's plucking whether he was the oc or
the hc so what what do you think is the
uh
is is the way that ohio state's gonna go
back to the drawing board and try and uh
try and beat michigan albert a lot of it
a lot of it rich is that this stuff that
you saw on saturday wasn't a one-off it
was
everything sort of coming crashing down
at once
and you saw the oregon game played out
very much like the michigan game right
like so that was about physicality on
both sides of the ball it makes you ask
the question with those great receivers
you have had you lost a little bit of
that edge because you know you practice
the way you play and if you're throwing
the ball around in practice are you you
know creating this sort of physicality
you need so i think that that's one
piece of it the red zone offense was a
problem all year that relates to the
running game the third down defense was
an issue during the year and so like
it's like all these things that happen
on saturday i think anybody who follows
ohio state would tell you
like everything came crashing down at
once right and so it's a good job by the
michigan coaches no question about it i
think you're going to see a new
defensive coordinator in columbus um i
think one thing that ryan day has sort
of struggled with was replacing jeff
haffley who did a fantastic job two
years ago and left as a result of that
to go to boston college yeah and then i
think you know creating a little bit
more of an edge on offense maybe they
had an assistant or two on that side of
the ball too
um but i can promise you the talent's
there the talents there it's just you
know i think that there were some
systemic issues with this year's team
that that all showed up at once and
um yeah i mean it's quite a scene on
saturday i wish i could have enjoyed you
know all of that the guy the team's
walking out of the tunnel that was
amazing falling down that's so great i
wish i could have enjoyed that quite the
same way i wish i could have enjoyed
that the way i
uh that you probably did you know at the
end of the day you could remove the word
probably
uh
absolutely positively definitely date in
his youtube i mean it was like that i i
i think when we get a couple months out
i'll be able to enjoy the scenery of
that because that was amazing it's a big
tent that's what a big ten game should
look like it's what it should look like
yeah hundred thousand people plus i've
said i've said this to people like i i'm
i'm on an island on this i sort of wish
the big ten championship game was at
soldier field
you know what i mean sure like i really
i really do like and and ohio state's
obviously been in indianapolis a lot you
know playing that game over the last
decade tonight there's just something
about it after you play on these and it
seems like we saw on saturday all year
long and then you go inside into a dome
to play the championship i don't know
there's just something to me that feels
like
that feels a little wrong you know what
i mean like i don't know but i'm but but
i think most coaches would tell you
they'd rather play inside so so be it
albert here on the rich eisen show how
will the uh brian kelly and lincoln
riley contracts affect
nfl coaches and nfl contracts because
the contract that brian kelly got just
in terms of terms and almost the dollars
but we assume he's going to reach
whatever incentives are there based on
his ability to win wherever he's been
and now he's at lsu
so
that contract
10 years 100 million dollars i should
say that that was gruden's deal that got
so many people sort of
uh upright in their chairs when he got
it from the the raiders albert how do
you think that's going to manifest
itself
well you know i think rich the first
thing is obviously i think they're going
to be some coaches that are going to say
how can i leverage that and i think
we've seen that some degree with cliff
in arizona and you know what happened
with the interest from oklahoma
so you know i think that's the first
piece which is you know pretty simple
like you know guys at that level i think
mel tucker is the one that got a lot of
people's attention to be honest with you
because
you know brian kelly you know has at
least won and been to the playoffs i
mean mel tucker and i think he's a great
i think i think he's done a great job at
michigan state but he's been there for
two years he's been a head coach for
three and so i think that was the one
that sort of you know moved the needle
and pushed some of these things in the
direction there that they've gone in
and so i think that's the first piece of
it the second piece of it's way more
interesting to me which is
what did you just see usc and lsu do
normally when it when a school is in
that sort of spot what they'll do
is they'll either go with to somebody
who has a connection to the school or
they'll go and say okay like let's go
find the hot group of five coach or
let's go find the guy who's at like a
minnesota or
a kentucky or something like that and
let's bring them up and have them in a
blue blood or let's go get the hot
coordinator at alabama
what did lsu and usc do they said the
hell with that we're not doing that
we're going to go to another blue blood
and we're going to steal that blue
bloods coach so lsu steals notre dame's
coach usc steel's oklahoma's coach
i have the effect that you could feel in
the nfl now more teams that have
openings may be willing to take swings
like that and we used to see this in the
nfl if you go back and you look like
what happened with bill parcells in 1997
what happened with john gruden in 2002
um coach trades
belichick yeah belichick and so like i
think if i'm an owner right now i'm
looking this i'm saying there's a little
bit of a shallow candidate pool this
year just because there's been so much
turnover over the last 10 years
is it worth if i'm chicago
calling new orleans and saying
is there anything we can do to get sean
payton here he's from chicago you get
him in there to work with justin fields
our general manager has a relationship
with him if you're the raiders and you
need to face the franchise a leader do
you call pittsburgh and say
like hey is there any way mike tomlin
might be interested in coming here
and you know a lot of this has to be
back channeled and everything else but
you know i i i was talking to a you know
an executive for an nfc team earlier in
the week and you know what he said to me
is the interesting part about this is
you do have some some coaches
who may be reaching their natural
conclusions in certain places like right
like so sean payton's been in new
orleans for
i think it's 16 years now yeah 2016. and
yeah and and he doesn't have a
quarterback right the roster is getting
a little older they've been fighting
through cap issues the last few years is
this just time um same in pittsburgh you
know the the general manager kevin
colbert might retire the quarterback
might retire
um you know they may actually wind up
having their first losing season which
is an incredible thing but first losing
season in 15 years with tomlin as a
coach tomlin has now been there as long
as bill cower was in pittsburgh which is
mind-blowing right so is it time for him
is it just a natural conclusion so
i think if i'm one of these nfl teams i
think there are a couple teams that are
thinking this way you look at what
happened with usc you look at what
happened with lsu
they went big game hunting so if you're
one of these teams do you look at and
say before we go down the normal path
and go and get a coordinator or go get a
retread
let's just at least look let's see if
somebody like sean payton or mike tomlin
is available it's an interesting idea i
think that a lot of teams are going to
take from what happened over the course
of the last week and how possible do you
think i know that's it's it's great food
for thought but
i mean the the sean payton one does
certainly fascinates because you know he
and pace know each other and that would
be another way for pace to try and and
uh and and and
keep his shelf life going in in chicago
but i i can't even imagine how much it
would cost right that would be
significant in terms of draft capital it
wouldn't be just a couple of fourths
right right it's it's complicated and
there's no question it's definitely
complicated and
i mean like look like here's the thing
is you have to find a way to back
channel it right because you don't want
to go
to that team
and then like go through the process and
then the coach decides oh well you know
like i don't want to do that like that
actually happened
um seven years ago you know between the
browns and niners with your coach jim
harbaugh where you know they kind of
gotten down the road where the browns
were willing to send two threes to san
francisco and you remember things
weren't good between the niners and arbo
at the time
and harbaugh decided basically like i
don't want to go i want to stay with the
niners in 2014.
so you don't want a situation like that
where you go down the road with another
team and it falls apart at the end so
you have to back channel some of this
but yeah i mean i think you know if
you're willing to give up draft picks i
think these things can happen are they
complicated yes do you have to back
channel a bunch of you know discussion
yes um you have to work through
intermediaries yes but i think it is
possible the reward could be really big
on the back end the other thing rich
can you think of a time in nfl history
when teams have been more willing to
part with draft picks i mean like you
look at like what the rams have done
right the rams gave up two first-round
picks for a corner jaylen ramsey great
player but two first-round picks for a
corner the texans gave up two
first-round picks for an offensive
tackle and laramie thompson so i think
that's the other piece of it is that
teams are maybe more willing than they
ever have been
to part for part with high-end draft
capital in order to bring in difference
makers and i think outside of having a
great quarterback there may not be a
bigger difference maker in a in a
football operation than a great netcast
senior nfl reporter the mmq b's albert
prier here on the rich eisen show so
let's get to your reporting on antonio
brown's three-game suspension same to go
with mike edwards back up safety and
then uh a free agent wide receiver john
franklin the third i give you the floor
what can you tell me yeah so like this
was sort of it's interesting because the
nfl's put the ball in the team's courts
on this and we saw this
you know a couple weeks ago with you
know the findings in the the aaron
rodgers situation and how the packers
were fine
um for letting you know aaron go to the
podium without his mask on um and so you
know in this case it was the same sort
of thing
where they were looking at the
buccaneers actions and then they were
looking at the player's actions and so
uh they found that the buccaneers hadn't
done anything wrong that they had gone
down all the proper channels um and that
they were deceived by the players too
i thought what was really interesting
about the whole thing
um is you know the three players the way
that they were flagged during the
investigation
they all had vaccination cards from this
place called citrus county florida now
i'm not familiar with it
or wasn't until the last 24 hours but
it's 90 minutes north of tampa
and um and it's got a population of 150
000 so i mean like this is a dot on the
map in in in florida
and uh yeah so i mean i guess the nfl is
just going through the vaccination cards
all right tampa tampa tampa tampa citrus
county tampa tampa tampa tampa citrus
county and so
um you know obviously they looked into
that and wound up uh busting those three
guys um and and then i think from here
where this goes uh i believe it's gonna
continue to leave it up to the teams to
enforce this stuff so
um you know short of you know another
story coming out rick stroud the tim
baitheheim did a great job you know
reporting on this you know over the last
couple of weeks
um that winds up you know fingering a
player for having a fake axe card i
don't know the league's going to get
very proactive in trying to find other
cases so
what about the buck's reaction to it
albert i mean because it's interesting
well because again as i pointed out at
the top of the show before you called in
arians has been treated for three forms
of cancer tom moore is 83 years of age
and of all the people to hand the fake
vaccination card to
as a as as the method to deliver it to
the bucks
uh antonio brown according to rick
stroud's reporting used uh alex guerrero
tom brady's god yeah he looped him into
it and he used him as a dupe here here
alex here's my fake card you the one you
you give it to the bucks
and so this is all cool like
a b can catch touchdowns let's have him
back like this is fine it's
it's crazy right like and i i think um
you know i i think the the worst part
about it rich you know like if this was
a player at the bottom of the roster
i guess it might be a little more
understandable because my might be a job
security issue right like i don't think
any of us would like that but
if that was the case like okay like i
kind of understand that this wasn't that
like a b wasn't getting cut you know
what i mean like this was literally
boiled down to his personal comfort like
he didn't want to wear a mask in the
build right so that's what makes it i i
think you know infinitely worse is that
like it's just i mean it's such a
selfish act you know
and we heard you know ba say last year
that he was on zero tolerance um you
know but that was a while ago and the
interesting part about to me is you know
and talking to some people about how the
[ __ ] struggled over that month where
they didn't win a game right
um one of the things that kind of
continually came up was like how
gronkowski and brown were
like sort of like luxury items last year
because they entered the full blade and
they were sort of integrated late and
they kind of like were like let's game
some stuff up for them and get them
making plays but we don't we're not
going to be overly relying on them
that's different this year you know one
of the things again that came up like
when
um when i was asking around about how
why the bucks were struggling was they'd
been integrated and brady really trusted
those two guys so when those two guys
got hurt the bucks often started
struggling in critical spots because
those were brady's guys
and so that's what makes this
fascinating is this is the guy who
brady's really come to rely on right we
know how important
and this is how much he respects that is
to hand a fake vaccination card to alex
guerrero you know what i'm saying
and that that that's the thing that's
the thing like now like you know brady's
priority is to win the super bowl right
so i mean like so
you know like if you're brady do you
like i mean do you excuse it i think
brady probably is so single-minded that
you know he just wants brown and on the
field in the playoffs but if you're ba
can you look the other way you know what
i mean like and it's just
it's i mean like i
you know the fact that they haven't
released him yet tells me that they're
going to um they're going to tolerate it
um but it obviously flies in the face of
a lot of things that have been said and
done there over the course block what
does he sit there thinking when when the
when the when the bucks rightfully or
touting you know uh proudly that they
were 100 vaccinated and he's walking
around the building like yeah we are
like you know i mean it's just i mean
it's like
you're making a liar of me right right
like that's the thing is like you you're
making a liar me you make me look bad
when you do this right
so and and like you said like that's
without even touching like the health
stuff which is
i mean they have like one of the oldest
coaching staffs in the league
i know it's like they're looking for the
pool house in cocoon you know what i
mean it's just right because they have
the fountain of youth there man it's
just
i i i don't i honestly thank you
tremendous is such a tremendously
selfish act you know like it's just it's
one of those things where
i guess you always like kind of the
equations always is a guy's talent
exceeded problems you know and that and
if
antonio brown has been sort of walking
that tightrope forever and um you know i
i i think that this is something that
you know i like if you're the box like
do you draw the line here or
is it just
winning a championship over everything
else and it doesn't matter we're going
to bring them in and we'll get them in
line for the last couple weeks the
regular season and then the five weeks
of the playoffs and we'll deal with this
after that maybe some you know they
become so single-minded i mean they
they've inherited brady's mindset down
there there's no question about that in
so many different ways
um it'll be interesting to see
you know whether or not they draw a line
here because again like that
single-mindedness would make you believe
like that they
they may find a way to tolerate this
especially when you consider that they
had an idea what was coming out you know
like they had night they they weren't
involved in the investigation they fully
cooperated in it with it so you would
think if they they were prepared for
what was going to happen on thursday
and if they were going to release him it
probably would have happened by now all
right albert thanks for the call greatly
appreciate what are you doing tomorrow
night what are you what are you going to
be up to tomorrow night
my plans have let go like you know this
has been such a staple for me for the
last like eight years yeah yeah yeah
yeah it's uh i'll i'll have to find
something to do now i'll be watching you
guys it'll because you're you're a big
ten guy you got a root for michigan to
represent the big ten in in in in the uh
in the big enchilada right you gotta you
gotta root beware of beware beware of
kirkparents
i don't even told that i could tell you
from experience but i know that i know
that but it's not in their house it's an
it's in a neutral site we'll see how
that goes thanks for the time albert
appreciate it
all right thanks rich good luck tomorrow
night thank you thank you sir i
appreciate that that's albert breer
right there on the rich eisenhower he's
gonna now go get more oxygen he's taking
such a big high road
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here